In the 1950s, scientists programmed a first-generation
computer to learn using the same rules as
the human brain.
This model is called a neural network.
It’s made up of many basic units that compute
by taking inputs from other units and passing
them on as simple calculations.
The answers are recorded by designated output
units.
Pathways strengthen, and the model learns,
when many different inputs result in the same
output.
Today, advanced versions of these models,
called deep neural networks, are the most
successful AI ever created.
They power image and speech recognition and
recognize patterns in massive sets of data,
making astonishing predictions about the future.
But there’s a dark mystery here: We have
no idea how deep neural networks work.
What happens inside their billions of hidden
layers that allows them to converge to a solution?
Now, for the first time ever, a group of researchers
has found a mathematical key that might just
open this black box.
Historically, a lot of methods in machine
learning were designed to have simple properties,
where the model designer was guaranteed that
they would obtain a certain solution if they
used a particular algorithm or model.
Deep neural networks move away from that paradigm.
The model designer chooses how many units
they would like to have in each one of the
hidden layers.
That’s often referred to as the width of
the neural network.
Yasaman Bahri and her colleagues at Google’s
Brain Team hoped to mathematically simplify
a deep neural network by considering an extreme
case: They took the networks’ width to be
infinite.
One of the goals was to understand what happens
in that limit of infinitely wide, deep neural
networks to see if we could say anything concrete
about it.
Incredibly, they could.
Bahri mathematically reduced those infinite-width
networks to something simpler called kernel
machines, algorithms with a history going
back to the 19th century mathematician Carl
Friedrich Gauss.
A kernel method captures a richness that is
similar to a deep neural network in terms
of its functional dependence on the input,
but it's simpler than a deep neural network
because it's linear and its parameters and
neural networks in general are non-linear.
Kernel machines find patterns in data by projecting
the data into extremely high dimensions.
They map each point on a low-dimensional data
set to a point in a higher dimension, and
then use the data point’s characteristics
to identify a class it belongs to.
They do this classification using a geometric
object called a hyperplane.
Kernel machines can compute infinite-dimensional
data while staying firmly in the realm of
lower dimensional space.
Bahri and her team were able to show that
kernel methods are mathematically equivalent
to an idealized version of a deep net–the
first major step to cracking open the black
box of deep learning.
It's very rare to have an exact equivalence
between two things, in particular if that
other thing is exactly solvable.
You can write down the expressions mathematically.
From my perspective, that's quite appealing.
If this equivalence can be extended beyond
idealized neural networks, it may explain
how practical deep neural networks achieve
their astonishing results.
To describe finite width networks, more work
is needed, but at least if you have an exactly
solvable model where you have that full handle,
you can then start to be systematic about
what's missing.
And so from my mind, that gives you a starting
point.
There is a great debate happening in the world
of set theory, the study of collections of
numbers and other mathematical objects.
It’s about the nature of infinity – or,
rather, infinities.
The remarkable thing about infinities is that
they come in different sizes.
Take two infinite sets of numbers.
If every number from one set can be paired
to a number from another, the sets are said
to be bijective, or the same size.
So it's not just the case that all infinite
sets are bijective with each other, that there's
a one-to-one correspondence between them.
You have actually lots of examples of sets
such that one is strictly smaller than the
other.
These questions about the sizes of infinities
go back nearly 150 years, when the German
mathematician Georg Cantor rocked the mathematical
world by discovering something that seems
counterintuitive: The infinite set of real
numbers, which includes every point on the
number line, outnumbers natural numbers – even
though there are infinitely many of both.
After all, you can try to pair up these sets,
but you would have skipped over an infinite
amount of real numbers between them.
In other words, these infinities are not equal.
The smaller one’s size, or cardinality,
was classified as aleph-zero, and the next
biggest size is aleph-one.
Cantor conjectured that this aleph-one is
exactly the size of the continuum of real
numbers.
In other words, there are no sizes of infinity
between the sets of natural and real numbers.
This came to be known as the continuum hypothesis.
But he could never prove it.
The axioms, or basic foundations of mathematics,
simply didn’t govern things like Cantor’s
infinity problem.
But this year, set theorist David Aspero and
his longtime collaborator Ralf Schindler got
closer to finding the answer anyway.
We had the right scenario in place about 10
years ago, but there was a missing ingredient.
And then it just came, just by chance, quite
randomly.
The breakthrough came when Asperó used a
technique, known as forcing, to create a mathematical
object called a witness.
He used this witness to verify that an extremely
powerful axiom, Martin’s maximum plus plus,
actually implies a rival axiom, star.
By unifying the two rival axioms, Asperó
and Schindler showed that they are both likely
true – implying that an extra size of infinity
actually does sit between the sets of natural
and real numbers.
This would prove that there are more reals
than Cantor had thought, finally bringing
closure to the 150-year-old mystery and offering
a coherent alternative to the continuum hypothesis.
But this is not even close to the end of the
story.
Newer and stronger axioms are already challenging
this result and a battle is underway to decide
which side is right.
The final chapter on the actual number of
real numbers – the true size of the continuum
– is yet to be written.
This is a Liouville field–or, at least,
an idea of it.
It’s a wildly chaotic mathematical surface
where the height of every point is chosen
at random.
Forty years ago, the theoretical physicist
Alexander Polyakov found a striking use for
these fields: as a model of quantum physics.
Polyakov intuited that they could do this
by unlocking the behavior of theoretical objects
called strings, and building a simplified
model of quantum gravity in two dimensions.
It can be seen as a toy model for higher-dimensional
cases, but it can also be seen as string theory,
because string theory in some sense is about
two- dimensional surfaces.
But Polyakov’s formula for understanding
the Liouville field stopped tantalizingly
short of being rigorous.
Although he attempted to explain it using
a path integral developed by Richard Feynman,
the Liouville field resisted being described
in this way.
Around the year 2013, we started looking at
Polyakov’s path integral and according to
what physicists were saying, if we could make
sense of this path integral, we could directly
construct in the continuum quantum gravity.
So we took the path integral and we said,
“Okay, let's give it a shot.
We're going to try to define it.”
Mathematician Vincent Vargas and his colleagues
set out to precisely describe Polyakov’s
path integral using a different approach:
probability theory.
They began by transforming the Liouville field
into a far milder object called a Gaussian
free field.
It's kind of this very rough landscape where
there are infinite spikes everywhere.
From the point of view of physics, the Gaussian
free field is a boring theory.
It's a trivial theory where everything is
computable straight away.
And what we realized and which came as a surprise,
I think, to the physics community, is that
we could express anything that you naturally
want to compute on this theory just in terms
of something on the Gaussian free field.
There were other leads to build on as well.
In 1984, as a potential workaround to his
failed path integral, Polyakov began trying
to develop a technique called the bootstrap
— a mathematical ladder that gradually builds
up to a full, complex representation of a
field.
By chance, two unrelated pairs of physicists
in the 1990s built on Polyakov’s bootstrap
and managed to completely solve the Liouville
field.
They called their formula “DOZZ."
Even though it seemed to work, it was a miraculously
lucky guess, and they couldn’t prove it.
This formula, which comes out of a black box–I
mean, it's black magic–well, it actually
has a probabilistic meaning.
So what we did is show that our path integral
probability construction is equivalent, completely
equivalent to that bootstrap construction.
Last year, they unveiled a new and improved
version of Polyakov’s path integral, defined
in terms of the Gaussian free field.
The work also explains the mysterious origins
of the DOZZ formula.
We're mapping probability theory to the bootstrap,
or, if I were just talking on the mathematical
side, we’re mapping probability theory to
representation theory.
And with that, they proved that the Liouville
field models quantum gravity, exactly as Polyakov
thought it would 40 years ago.
By bridging these two fields of math which
are really distinct, a priori it enables us
to compute things that physicists don't know
how to compute.